hey what's going on
what's going on it's bill burr and it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh september 14th
2020 what's going on how are you
2020 yeah the story of 2020 has been
coveted 19
affecting all aspects of the economy you
can't even
barbecue with somebody not bringing it
up
um i'll tell you last night i came home
and there was some youngsters i don't
know where they were the couple the
house next door is what they sounded
like
they were having a party they sounded
really young
because every five seconds they were
going whoa
this [ __ ] is just like me my wife
will [ __ ]
die and laughing it's like are they
doing
shots cheering each other on i don't
know what it is
and i was like you know they better keep
it down or somebody's gonna call the
cops
um i don't know if they did but you know
one of my proudest
moments as an adult is i've never called
the cops on young people having a good
time
i've definitely been annoyed by young
people
[ __ ] [ __ ] riding their bikes in
the middle of the goddamn
street you know the the skateboard kids
i mean they're just the [ __ ] worst i
mean i don't know
i mean if you want your kid to achieve
as a skateboarder i think
like the number one thing you have to do
is just be an [ __ ] dad because so
many skateboarders they just got this
[ __ ] chip on their shoulder it's like
what is the what is the problem
you know don't they make those little
[ __ ]
areas for you to go do that [ __ ] i think
half the fun of skateboarding is having
some
fat [ __ ] security guard chase you off
the lot if it doesn't happen then they
just try and pick a fight with somebody
in his prius
picking up his goddamn dry plant
um anyway but no that that is a big
thing for me like i don't i don't
rat people out i'm not calling the cops
um and i know better than to come over
there and be like hey can you keep it
down yeah you know my guy my daughter's
sleeping in one of
like i came in the house and my daughter
was still up at 10 30. she's going
dad dad
trying to ignore her dad finally just go
i go what buddy what
she goes i heard you out like went into
a room she goes i heard you outside
uh going whoa
that wasn't me she goes well who was it
i got some kids over there having fun
and she's like i want to play with them
you know um she's hilarious her new
thing now
is um her new thing now is [ __ ]
like if i'll be like sweetheart don't
run she goes i'm not running
or i'll be like chew your food she's
like i am chewing my food
um i know it's pushback and i know it's
disrespectful but it's [ __ ] hilarious
to me
because i actually respect it you know i
am chewing my food you know stop
micromanaging me
even though you know she needs me to but
i like the fact that she doesn't like to
be micromanaged and i don't know where
she picked that up from
i first noticed it when we were in the
grocery store
um when now
i don't know i don't know where we were
i i just get so paranoid
when i'm in public with my my daughter i
always just make sure
like i'm holding her hand head on a
swivel i always know where she is at all
times and i'm one of those people like
she gets more than three feet away from
me like buddy come on get over here get
over here
there's always have like these [ __ ] i
think it's just part of being a parent
you just have these horrible [ __ ]
thoughts of i don't know what i didn't
want to talk about it so
um anyway so i guess i was just doing it
too much
and i was like buddy don't run don't run
she goes i'm not running
she said it like will you stop bitching
at me
um that's been the hardest thing so far
for me
um as a parent is uh
is trying to discipline the kids because
the [ __ ] they say is
well my son's not talking yet but the
stuff my daughter says it's just so
goddamn
funny that half the time
i'm disciplining her i have half a smile
on my face which gets her smiling and
then we both start laughing
and you know i'm worried that i'm not
making my point every once in a while
though
i do uh i do have to make a point raise
my voice a little bit
and she gets all upset but um the big
thing with us
is over this you know i've been home for
so long
i've learned how to braid her hair and
everything so uh the latest one that
i've been working on is uh
the french braid which was really
difficult for me at first now i have it
down
it's just i think i'm grabbing too much
hair and then you also got to really pay
attention to where your braid is going
and all of that but i'm just going to do
it like uh
you know every day and i'm just i'm
going to get it down and um
what's cool is she actually likes she
she says to me she goes dad i like when
you braid my hair i was sitting oh it's
great because we're bonding with each
other but then i realized
she likes it because she holds my phone
while i do it and she watches all her
favorite like pixar and
um you know she always watches the bear
necessities
and then uh the latest one which i don't
think i ever saw the movie but that josh
gad one i think i talked about this
already when he's the snowman
and he wants to experience summer in
summer
he's doing that whole thing she thinks
it's the funniest thing
ever and um so she gets to watch all of
those so
it's it's really amazing little girls
how
early on like they can just
they're like jedi's like my daughter
already like when she wants something
she came up to me the other day
and she wanted like a cookie or
something like that and she came up to
me stood up on the couch walked over me
she goes hey dad
i'm like what's up buddy and she's just
like um
and she put her arm around me and
started smiling
and then i just start laughing because i
know she wants something and then she
starts laughing because she knows that i
know what she's doing
and then she starts cracking up i start
cracking up
and then she literally started like
playing with my ear
going i i still hungry could i have a
chocolate chip cookie and i just start
laughing and she laughed she knows what
she's doing i know what she's doing
but she's just not she's not good at it
yet
because my wife does it to me all the
time and by the time i realize
what she did it's it's the the event has
already come and gone
um but anyway uh
so i'm recording this thing right now uh
in the afternoon here sunday while the
buccaneers are playing the saints
tom oh he got sacked tom brady looks
[ __ ] as great as he ever did
you know he just has to get on the same
page you know with some of these guys
here
somebody just broke off a route a skinny
post as they call it which i don't even
know what that means
is that a sharper post i have no idea
shorter one i have no idea so he did
throw a pic but
um i do like uh
i he just looks as great as he ever did
which i'm really happy for him
but um that's the hardest thing about
watching him in a buccaneers uniform i
know players come and go
the hardest thing is just seeing how
good he still is but uh
having said that the patriots got a win
against one of our toughest
teams you know the dolphins we uh
we all oh and they block the [ __ ]
field goal
holy [ __ ] the wheels are coming off here
wow tampa wayne right down went up seven
to nothing
now the saints have scored two
touchdowns and they just blocked a field
goal and drew brees the most
underrated greatest quarterback of all
[ __ ] time
i mean i can't even believe like how
much that they don't give that guy
any [ __ ] he barely gets any notice
um i don't know
it's weird the stats that that guy has
versus the [ __ ]
attention he gets but anyway how about
the [ __ ] lions
blowing that lead against the bears you
know i know everybody's gonna jump on
that kid who dropped
the touchdown pass but i think a lot of
other [ __ ] also got [ __ ] up before
that happened but i gotta tell you you
gotta make that catch come on man
um i love the lions at matthew stafford
you know
uh i've always liked them i got family
out there i got family back each i got
family out there in michigan so i've
been always been a fan of uh
you know the lions and the tigers uh not
the pistons because
because of the celtics and um
what else red wings i always liked i
like the wolverines
michigan wolverines hail to the victors
um but anyways let's talk the patriots
um
yeah it was a solid victory i thought
for all the new personnel we had on d
our d looked pretty solid we did take
some past interference
calls towards the end um all of them i
thought
you know there was one borderline one
but other than that i mean we got away
with one in the end like they easily
could have called
that one that we uh the interception we
made in the end zone but i still don't
think that
the dolphins had enough time uh
would have had enough time who knows i
shouldn't say that i'd be pissed if i
was a dolphin fan
and admittedly as a patriots fan that
was interference
and i was surprised they didn't call it
um
but uh let's talk some positive here uh
edelman had five catches loved seeing
that that he was getting open
um harry had five catches i think too um
was hoping to see more i hope to see
i mean it's only the first game i hope
to see harry be involved
more which will be great for edelman
and will be great for cam newton because
um
i don't think even as big and as tough
and as great as cam newton is i don't
think you want your top rush or every
game to be your quarterback
which he was he had more yards than sony
michelle and um
you know ran for 75 yards or something
like that but uh
yeah yeah i don't know it's i it's gonna
take a minute to
to adjust i mean we've had the same
quarterback for two decades
so um i don't know
but cam was smiling he looked like he
was having fun and
uh he's a phenomenal quarterback and an
incredible
athlete just the whole thing so um i'm
hoping it's just going to get better
having said that uh watching this saints
um tampa bay game obvious it's the first
week so who knows but like
these teams both look better than what i
saw
either by the patriots or the dolphins
um
and green bay obviously looked pretty
good too scoring all of those points but
let up a ton of points too
so i don't know the green bay fans are
you excited about that you know you
[ __ ] score like 43 points but you let
up 34.
and don't give me that oh that last one
was garbage time no it counted that last
touchdown counted
uh and the two-point conversion so who
knows um i'm just psyched that it's back
thank you to the nfl thank you to the
college teams that are playing football
um thank you for not listening to all of
these [ __ ] people um
these people are getting tested all the
goddamn time
um i think it's super safe and uh
you know it's about it's just like a
bunch of nerds that just they just don't
like sports and they got
you know it's kind of the athlete's
fault you know at some point i think
half of these scientists got stuffed in
a [ __ ] locker by somebody that played
at least lacrosse or something and just
in general
you know they they resent these guys
they i i think scientists
you really have to resent the fact that
right now
if you're working on curing covid
and you have the brain capacity to be
one of the select few
that works on problems of this level and
there's not groupies waiting for you you
don't need security
as you go out to to your you know your
mid-sized sedan to drive home
there's not a bunch of [ __ ] all-star
game level [ __ ]
waiting to lift up your lab coat and
service you
it's unbelievable the life that
entertainers live
uh but i will say football players and
athletes in general i feel like they
earn
you know the extracurricular uh ass that
they get
just because of of what they put their
bodies through
um you know what i mean
comedians you know we go through a
little bit of humiliation but at the end
of all this we can still walk right
um i don't know i gotta look that up do
you think there's any there's any
scientist groupies there has to be and
like where would you hang out
how do you meet them how do you meet a
[ __ ] scientist
um all right let's let's look that this
is so stupid why don't why do i do these
searches here
my only defense is going to be that i i
do these on the podcast and i'll
actually have the audio to defend myself
okay people i'm adding this to my
internet history
scientist
groupies what do you guys think huh is
there going to be something here
scientist groupies come on you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my internet sucks what do you got to
do what do you how much do you gotta
[ __ ] pay
uh the groupies of scientists these are
the groupies of scientists these
non-scientists who for one reason or
another choose to build their whole
social lives around
science this is just people that are
into science
groupie the term groupie is a slang word
that refers to a fan of a particular
musician celebrity
uh groupies revisited the women with aaa
access to the 60s
oh these are people who bang the rolling
stones
science groupies i think so you know
what
science is such a nerd thing or a smart
person thing
that it's basically
to be a groupie you just have to be into
science
you know everything else if you're like
uh
you know back in the day i used to hear
this when there was like
groupies for comedians if there was a
particular woman
that uh banged a number of comics she
was referred to as a chuckle [ __ ]
it was a term that was around for about
a year and a half two years
and i remember i thought it was so
goddamn funny because i was just like
there's just something about being a
comedian that like none of it is
uh god damn it i love the titans
uniforms
look at that [ __ ] running back that's
the guy that destroyed the patriots last
year look at him just
ragged all the people down the [ __ ]
field
what is that do you know what he just
looked like on that plate
i i need to learn his name i know i'm an
old man i need to learn that guy's name
he just looked like you ever see like
when they'll show like a clip
of like earl campbell when he was in
high school and he's just a man
child he just did that in the nfl
stiff arm three nfl layer level players
for like [ __ ] 80 yards and scored a
touchdown
wow wow that is something else i did not
see today on either side of the ball
with the patriots play in the dolphins
so we shall see
here where this is going to go but uh
i'm very excited that this is back
i called my cable company because i'm an
old man and i still have the cable
and uh or directv i called him up i
always waited the
[ __ ] day of to order the nfl package
i said we're experiencing a very high
caller volume can you go to the website
and go [ __ ] yourself
and i don't i just put on my headphones
and i listen to whatever music that they
have
and i just chill out and it took me uh
28 minutes
something seconds to uh to get it
established and now i have
i have the [ __ ] um i have the nfl
package for the year and i'm very
excited i'm watching every second of
patriots football i'm watching every
tampa bay buccaneer game uh
i gotta watch that kid on the titans i
hope they i really hope they got a
monday night game
uh oh look at the screen all set up he's
at the 40. the 35 to 30.
that 25 he's still going down at 20.
look how fast these goddamn people are
all right i shouldn't be watching this
game because it's making me feel less
enthused
about where whatever we just seem like
we're going to be this grinded out
running team
um i don't know we need to get a better
we
you know i can't i don't want to [ __ ] on
my team but like i just i just wish
i could have saw more of cam newton
standing in the pocket
you know throwing passes rather than
having to third and long
you know turn into superman and as he
does
to get a uh to get a first down um
i don't know we shall see so with that
let's talk stand up here oh billy
redface has been doing spots i did
two last night one the night before i'm
doing another tonight
um i've been having a great time i did
the
magic castle parking lot last night and
then i went out to eagle rock
literally stood in the bed of a pickup
truck
and did stand up to a bunch of people
sitting out and it was [ __ ]
great i had such a great time and
uh i saw a bunch of people i haven't
seen in a while
i did uh andrew santino's podcast but i
haven't seen him
since you know whenever this [ __ ]
started tom segura was there there's a
whole bunch of people
just going up there killing it and
um
i was like i kind of like shook the rust
off because i got this this run of dates
coming up
and um i got a long set somewhere
next what is it next weekend
i got one where i'm going to try to do
like an hour because on my tour coming
up that's what i'm going to be doing
i'll be doing an hour
and um i just got to make sure
i know after two shows i'm gonna be fine
but i just don't want
my first two shows on the tour to me
be me trying to figure out that last 20
minutes so
uh tonight i'm gonna be doing material i
didn't do
the last night last night so i can get
uh
so i have done all of it i have it and
that way
i can hit the ground running when i go
on the road and that is a big
[ __ ] thing for me and it's a big
mistake that i saw a lot of comics
headliners make um
you know when i was coming up i used to
watch these people and you know i would
open for people
that were i had a level of fame had a tv
show or whatever
and whatever they were out here in la
and they were busy
and then they would go out on the road
and that you know
thursday show the friday show they'd be
shaking the cobwebs off and then by
saturday
they'd be back up they would be having a
you know a good time and then most of
them went home before the sunday show
let's say they do a sunday show but like
half their weekend
was shaking the rust off and rather than
going up there and killing it they were
just doing a good job and that's
the competition is so fierce and fierce
it's really fierce
um and stand up that you can't afford to
do that
you you you have those shaking off the
rust is for
when you pop in to do a show you know
at the local club and you're just doing
20 minutes and and whatever and they're
going to see a whole potluck
hodgepodge of different types of people
uh when your name is on the marquee
um you have a responsibility you got to
go up there and [ __ ] murder or those
people they're not going to come back
they're not going to come back so that
is what has been haunting me
um i've been a little bit busy here uh
i'm working on this show um that's gonna
be coming out on quibby
that i'm very excited about so i've been
writing some stuff
and uh we shoot tomorrow then i'll have
that behind me
and uh i think it's going to be a great
show i can't tell you too many details
about it but i think it's really going
to be a great show
i'm very excited to be a very small part
of it
and um
what else yeah i think that's all i can
tell you about that oh by the way
uh how great is fitzgerald's beard by
the way for the dolphins
you know i don't know who shapes that
thing up
but he's got like the santa claus thing
going on down the bottom then he keeps
the mustache in the side like really
short it's like he
the the fact that he's not a viking he
should be on the vikings man
he literally looks like their logo then
all he's got to do
is grow his hair you know what's funny i
was watching uh the end of the
vikings packers game and i've been doing
my daughter's hair so much that when i
looked
at the vikings logo when i looked at
that braided ponytails like i know how
to do that
[Laughter]
what is happening to me i've always
loved the vikings logo
i never once noted that he noticed that
he had braided [ __ ] hair
i always loved the stash
i always just thought like now that is a
[ __ ] mustache
right it's the faux fu man shoe and then
it just is just hung down like perfectly
comes to a point
jesus christ i mean that's what it's all
about right there you come
walking into a [ __ ] bar with golden
locks and that [ __ ] mustache hanging
down there i'm telling you
you don't need to be a scientist or an
athlete you're gonna every chick in the
bar is gonna be a [ __ ] groupie right
um anyway let me see if this actually
sent me any of the advertising stuff
here oh by the way i haven't been
talking about my
shoulder lately um knock on wood it
feels great
yesterday after having a great set
i actually went to run up these three
steps and you know my eyes are going
here
and i uh i kind of missed the first one
like just the the my toes just caught
the first one so i did that
starting to land and then continuing to
fall skip step
so i went down and i stopped myself with
both hands
and that used to be enough to throw out
my shoulder
sorry what the [ __ ] did i eat that i got
indigestion here um
but it didn't it didn't throw out my
shoulder i felt a little bit of a twinge
throw a little ice on it today and i'll
be fine but i'm up to like 16
reps with uh with the two pound weight
i'm moving on to bands now i am past
recovery it is now full-on [ __ ] rehab
and re-strengthening the shoulder and uh
i cannot [ __ ] wait to get i miss
lifting weights
so much and i don't care if it's just
like
lighter weight or something like that
for the rest of my life i need to do it
i'm a child of the 80s and that's that's
just what it's just what the [ __ ] you
did
um you lifted weights and you never did
squats
it was essentially how it all went down
um
all right here we go let's see here
come on loading loading loading how much
[ __ ] longer
nah he hasn't sent him yet you
[ __ ] what are we gonna do here
well it's my fault cause i ended up
starting this thing
without telling it to him without
telling the great andrew themeless that
i needed all this [ __ ] material
so what else hey did i call it or what
huh i just knew i just [ __ ] knew the
celtics were gonna beat
the toronto raptors i don't know why
i just i i just wasn't nervous i just
felt the way that the series was going
that i i knew that we were going to
answer
and i really feel like if the celtics
had won game six
and if that made it 3-3 because i know
if we won game six we would have closed
out the series but let's just say we
were down 3-2 if we won
game six and made it 3-3 i feel like
toronto would have beat us it was one of
those
um it was just one of those series
you know i thought toronto was just as
good as we were but it was just one of
those back and forth back and forth back
and forth and i just i don't know i just
knew we were too good
to lose um
you know four out of five games i just
didn't see us doing that
and uh how about tatum with that huge
rebound off the miss free throws
to give us the win i was so [ __ ]
psyched and now we got
the miami heat who look like world
beaters
um which doesn't bother me you know the
clippers are looking like world beaters
too keep
you know very quietly the la clippers
are going to go to the east the western
conference finals it's looking like and
i can't remember
if that's ever happened when blake
griffin was there it didn't happen i
can't remember
but um i got to tell you if it's the
lakers and the clippers
um in the western conference final and
the clippers beat the lakers first of
all as a celtics
fan you know hating on the lakers my
whole [ __ ] life respecting him but
hating on him
um i i really
like i can't imagine like
i i've always dreamed of the mets
beating the yankees in the world series
i just think that that would be [ __ ]
hilarious but as bad as that would be i
think actually the clippers beating the
lakers
in the playoffs would be uh
i don't know why i just think it would
be worse here's another thing too you
know because i always [ __ ]
you know i'm on the rag about these
pylon [ __ ] teams
um i will say this i i when i look back
at the showtime lakers
like i [ __ ] love every one of them
now i hated them during the 80s but now
i look back
i loved them they were unbelievable
basketball players absolutely loved them
but when i look back
on pylon teams it's not the same thing
and i can't figure out why i just think
maybe it's because they come together so
quickly and then
you know dissipate again so quickly you
don't have a time you don't have time to
like really
get into the players and and then you
know as the years goes by and the same
players just keep facing each other
and they've played you know like two or
three six seven game series
you got like 30 playoff games of
memories
of these guys just going to war um
i don't know it's i do miss that i'll
tell you right now whatever [ __ ]
tampa bay was doing the saints seem to
have figured it out
okay and tampa bay needs to go in during
the halftime and make some halftime
adjustments here they're getting to
brady they're knocking balls down and
they're clogging up the lanes whatever
the [ __ ] they say
um i will say this
sorry to me that a lot i will say this
that it was [ __ ] wild
after all of these years to have to see
a new england patriot quarterback be
mobile um
oh look at tom nobody works the refs
like tom brady you love seeing it
you love seeing he just gives him a look
come on i got to throw the flag for you
um that was actually against tampa it
shows you what the [ __ ] i know
um anywho i guess this [ __ ] political
uh political this presidential race is
really heating up huh
i've been seeing all these goddamn ads i
love political ads
they're just just cause they're just so
friggin one-sided
you know they showed one
this great one trump had trash and joe
biden he's just showing all these people
it's going to take away all the jobs
you just see all these people that had
jobs with the sad look on their face
i mean and then joe biden has one
you know my kid had cancer and he wants
to take away obamacare
that's personal to me and he's like oh
and i think i'm voting for [ __ ] joe
biden
the things are just so like
you know i don't know they're just so
one-sided it's just like all right why
did he get rid of obamacare
you know was there something else
attached to it why is joe biden getting
rid of jobs
is that what he's [ __ ] doing like i i
haven't
i have no idea what any of these things
mean and what's funny
is if you're honest with yourself don't
everybody knows who they're voting for
already it's the biggest waste of time
that'd be a baller move if trump did
that
i'm not doing the debates people already
know who they're voting for you imagine
me one again
um the upside of trump getting
re-elected
is we're already halfway done with them
you know it wasn't that long
of four years personally speaking i
don't know
i always just look at if i'm not into
the person who's president and they get
reelected which is what usually happens
people go with what they know
um i always think well you know we're
halfway done with this guy this is fine
and then it'll go back the other way
you know maybe like a [ __ ] 80 year
old hillary clinton
an app is enough again and she'll
[ __ ] run
um the worst thing is when somebody
finally uh look at these [ __ ] diva
receivers every time there's an
incomplete pass they want a [ __ ] flag
tommy wants a flag
look at the passion still still gives a
[ __ ]
i'm going to tell you right now tom
brady is going to redefine
what it means to go to another team this
late in your career and have success i'm
telling you he is
oh he did get there early he did get
there early
there you go tom give him hell um
you know what's funny is they keep
saying hello patriots fans can't stand
to see him in a [ __ ]
this uniform which obviously is true but
i i don't know one pats fan that's not
rooting for tom and is not watching this
game i want to see gronk get a [ __ ]
catch here
uh the tampa bay patriots i don't give a
[ __ ]
i'd love to see him win it if we don't
that's the best i can do right that's
that's the most
class act that i can be
people i'm not gonna lie i'm just
[ __ ] killing time right here i'm just
waiting
for the ad reads to get in here um oh
[ __ ]
lamar what's his face huh on the ravens
crushing it
right he crushed it today
russell wilson crushed it today pat's
got [ __ ] seattle
and i'm just sitting there going like ah
seattle the big rivalry it's like wait
tom brady's not on the patriots
sherman's on the 49ers
you know it's like a whole different
i don't know what it is that's going to
be a weird game
you know where we kind of hate each
other i feel like seattle fans and
patriots fans really hate each other but
like
i don't know everybody from those days
is gone so it's just sort of the logo i
guess you know belichick's still there
and uh
sneaky pete carroll oh old backdoor pd
where you go pete leave that
championship trophy here there peto
tube um speaking of which i was supposed
to solo on uh
on thursday my first solo in a couple of
years because i haven't had the time to
fly as much as i wanted to to
feel like you know safe enough because
i'm overly overly overly safe about it
and i was supposed to fly on uh supposed
to solo on thursday
and you know we got all these fires and
[ __ ] going on out here and
i just looked at the visibility and it
was like six you know six miles and i
was just like you know what [ __ ] that
and then i looked at a map at the of the
fires and where i was gonna fly
there was like three fires surrounding
it and i'm just like there's gonna be
people flying helicopters trying to put
this thing out the last thing i need is
some jerk-off like me
you know in a [ __ ] r-22 flying around
out there so
uh i decided not to do it and then what
was hilarious just like two hours later
i walked outside the house and it
literally smelled like i was standing
over a campfire so
um and my instructor who's the best
[ __ ] pilot i've ever flown with
i told him i said hey i just it's a
no-go for today
and he wrote uh i said i don't feel
comfortable flying in this [ __ ]
i didn't say [ __ ] in this stuff and then
he wrote he wrote back
uh you know smart decision
and uh which is as good as if i had a
successful solo flight because half of
this [ __ ]
is um if you have to
you have to go within your level of
comfort
and um i haven't said that i've been
flying so much
um which is why i'm gonna do the solo
but i was um flying so much we've been
doing like these advanced auto rotations
which has just been
the most incredible thing um and
confidence
builder um
i've just worked on all of the stuff
that was
causing my attitude when i entered it to
be wrong and then the stuff that i was
doing wrong in the end of the
auto rotation and uh
it's such a i don't know i don't know if
you have to fly to understand it but
it's such a
feeling of accomplishment to start to
feel
one with with with the with the
helicopter and um
it's really something that i'm just
going to continue to do uh
you know i've been trying to find like a
used one i found a good
used one and it got bought really
quickly
um you know just a little two-seater
nothing fancy
and uh i've just been [ __ ]
i just been [ __ ] dying to get it
dying to get one i don't know we'll see
we'll see
every time i bring it up i'm just
bullshitting
you know as you get to a [ __ ] hobby
and you're like i'm gonna [ __ ] buy
that and then you never do but
um what am i looking at i'm looking at
the cabri
uh what is it three whatever the [ __ ]
they call it
it's basically the r22 the the
uh the french company that builds it
they looked at the r22
which is a great helicopter that i fly
um but you know
it was designed 40 [ __ ] years ago
they uh basically took it apart and when
they designed their helicopter
everything that they thought was good
about the 22 they kept and anything that
needed to be improved
they improved and um
three-bladed system fully uh articulated
main rotor system
um nicer interior
harder landings you know with with less
uh
can handle harder landings all of this
type of stuff um but
there is something hilarious about
because with the r22
is if you were to slam the collective
forward i don't know why maybe if you
get in like
or if you got into like really bad
turbulence and it just changed your
attitude like that you can get into
something known as a low g pushover
so i guess some guy had one of these
cabries and he was trying to show
that with the fully articulated main
rotor system you could
you could push the the stick forward
and not have any mass bump or low g push
over any of that [ __ ] right
well on the cabri it has the same
uh carbureted engine as the r22 except
it's inverted
and however that worked out when he
pushed it forward he starved the engine
of gas
uh fuel and he [ __ ] killed his engine
and he had to auto rotate
and do a little [ __ ] crash landing i
think he [ __ ] the hell i'm not
laughing i feel bad cause he
messed up the helicopter he didn't die
look at joe burrows
i love it i [ __ ] love it
aaron rodgers yeah you got to give that
guy an extra shout out for his beards
covid beard's looking great
um mitch trabitsky
leading the [ __ ] comeback oh it's
mitchell now mitchell trubisky
right cam newton 155 yards
throwing uh passing and 75 receiving
all right we got to get this guy some
weapons i swear to god i think the the
big thing
with tom brady is he had he had we had
no offensive line last year
uh our center i guess was out he had
some sort of problem
and uh he had nobody to [ __ ] throw to
and i think that that was probably
just his age he probably didn't have
time to go through a rebuild
so i guess that's how he ends up there
but i would really like to see
uh i would really like to see [ __ ]
cam newton have some weapons somebody
needs to step up
that'll free up edelman and we all know
what the [ __ ] he can do right
okay look at this i got my reads here oh
beautiful
loading loading loading and there they
aren't come on you [ __ ]
uh the cabri g3 is that what it's called
i don't know what it is here we go all
right
oh look who's here everybody hey hey
it's my bookie hey how the [ __ ] you
doing how the [ __ ] are you doing
i want to put some money on these
[ __ ] games uh all right
my bookie week two promotional offer
new customers can sign up with promo
code burr to double their deposit
and receive an instant cash bonus uh
survivor street contest begins
week two of the nfl season make bets
against the spread every week until you
go bust
only five dollar re-entry
um at my bookie it's winning uh
it's winning season sorry gonna enlarge
this year which means nfl football is
back
and it's time to take advantage of all
the action free bets
super contests survivor streaks and
deposit matches the survivor streak i
don't know what that is but that just
sounds like that's like way back in the
day
wrestling days um whatever that is i
already love it uh all
all for those who dare to put their
money where their mouth is the my bookie
survivor streak contest is open for
entry and accepting all
challenges all challenges because
winning
season is about more than just bragging
rights you gotta bring home the bacon
with my bookie you can choose from
thousands of bets on your favorite
sports like nfl
nba and mlb and odds on all your
favorite teams and players
if you sign up with my bookie right now
they're matching your deposit
dollar for dollar every cent up to a
thousand bucks will be put right back
into your account
all you have to do is use the promo code
burr b-u-r-r to claim your bonus
winning season is here and it's only at
my bookie how the [ __ ] you doing
all right okay we got some of my
favorites this week butcher box
oh i love butcher box butcher box is
great
pandemic or not it's even better during
a pandemic
all these people clamoring going down to
the supermarket butcher box brings it
right to your door
all right when it comes to me quality
matters
but there's there's more to that there's
more to it than texture and taste
uh talk about the hidden cost with low
quality meat
well i'm not i'm not in that [ __ ] i
don't sell meat i don't know what that
is
i know i know if you if you if you buy
cheap meat you have no idea what they
fed it what it [ __ ]
what it ate yeah you i didn't think i
had to explain that
um why is high quality humanely raised
meat important to you
well because i want the animal to have a
great life before they kill it and feed
me
right i don't want us messing with
mother nature all the obvious
what is your favorite cut of meat oh
i'll tell you right now i love a pork
chop
i love a pot roast i love a steak
i like after you know you make a couple
extra pork chops and then the next day
you know
you cut it all up and then you get a
little little [ __ ] tangy sweet and
sour [ __ ] thing going in your little
saucepan you let that reduce down to a
nice thickness then you toss that pork
in that
right then you take out a nice flour
taco okay you make yourself a little
[ __ ] uh white boy carne
whatever the [ __ ] that shit's called um
i'm on a massive tear right now hitting
like every [ __ ] taco stand possible
um hang on a second
jesus christ somebody just shot a
[ __ ] cop
in la county oh my god
dude this is just this is just bad man
this is just it's ugly times when are we
gonna be acting like human beings again
all right another reason not to go out
to the supermarket there's a bunch of
[ __ ] lunatics out there
uh anyways i like pork chops
how do you like to prepare it i just
said it uh not everyone
has convenient access to high quality
meat which is [ __ ]
it can be hard to eat healthy and it can
be harder to find 100 grass-fed
finished beef free-range organic chicken
my favorite
heritage breed pork or wild caught
salmon you don't know what they're gonna
do at the grocery store each box has 9
to 11 pounds of meat enough for 24
individual meals
packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way
i can customize my box or go with one of
theirs either way i get exactly what i
want
it's the best meat ship right to my
which means one less trip to the grocers
uh butcher box is the most affordable
and convenient way to get healthy
humanely raised meat with butcher bucks
you get the highest quality meat around
for just six dollars a meal and they
even have free shipping nationwide
except alaska and hawaii right now
butcher box is offering new members
ground beef for life that's two pounds
of ground beef in every box for the life
of their subscription just go to
butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com burr
oh look who's back
honey could you just is there any way
you could
honey these days it feels like online
shopping is the only shopping we really
do
uh that's where toa that's where today's
sponsor
honey comes in it's free it's the free
browser
extension that sources the internet for
promo codes and automatically applies
the best one available
at checkout this is like modern day uh
those coupons
that the old ladies used to uh have to
cut out of the uh newspaper this thing
you just click a button
honey is basically your online shopping
best friend
here's how it works you get honey on
your what are you saying
uh i'm reading the copy sweetheart
[ __ ] relax
you get honey on your computer for free
and two easy clicks by going to
joinhoney.com
that's h-o-n-e-y for all you dopes out
there uh
then when you're checking out on one of
its over 30 000
supporter sites honey pops up and all
you have to do is click apply coupons
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons for that site
if honey finds working codes it'll apply
the best ones to your cart honey
has found it's over 17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings
honey supports all kinds of retailers uh
from tech
and gam gaming sites to fashion brands
to even
food delivery it's simple if you have a
computer
oh honey should be on it it's free and
works whenever you're brow
uh wherever you brow wait it's free and
works with whatever browser you use you
can get honey
for free today at joinhoney.com that's
join honey
h-o-n-e-y dot com slash burb b-u-r-r
uh lastly but not leastly look who's
back oh
zip
monica stacks could relate
she needed to hire i feel like i didn't
get all the copy monica stacks could
relate
she needed to hire for a pivotal role at
her construction company
gs group but was having a tough time
finding the right person
especially with so many candidates out
there yet
so she switched to zip recruiter zip
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience for your job and
job and actively invites them to apply
which is why you should try ziprecruiter
for free
at ziprecruiter.com that's how monica
found lamont you big dummy jenkins
uh she said that zip
[Music]
sent lamont's profile to to her around
five minutes after she posted her job
because
he was a great match for the role
through zip
monica's company has hired everyone from
accountants to project manage to field
scientists but monica's not the only
employer who loves zip recruiter
four out of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day
see for yourself how ziprecruiter makes
hiring faster and easier
try it now for free that's right free at
ziprecruiter.com
i p r e c r u i t e
r dot com slash burr all right
and with that it's time to go into your
questions here for the week
okay second half kickoff here's a
touchback 17-7
your new orleans saints all right
the cast system in india take it from a
brahmana all right hi
redheaded gingerbread
uh was surprising that you brought the
indian cast system
i was surprised that oh it was
surprising that you brought
the indian cast system up on your
podcast delighted to see
billy boy becoming globally woke
um i wouldn't say i'm not i mean
everybody knows about the cast system
it's kind of out there isn't it
um anyway but thank you for the
compliment you know i don't take
compliments
all right go down to the next window for
that [ __ ] i'm here for the uh billy red
pubes comments uh
i am an indian live here
i am here meaning india live here i am
also an upper cass
brahmana so yeah oh do they have like
the rankings like the college football
rankings in the cast system let's see if
i can find that
all right brahman
and are you allowed to bang chicks in a
different cast
you know how does it all work let's see
let's see here cast system
names
why does it keep saying brahmin bags
the caste system brahman and i'm not
gonna try to say this
system is the social hierarchy india is
not limited to ancient india
it is still prevalent today according to
a something something in the world
religion the caste system
is its system of social stratification
i'm not these are too many big words
here all right let's get back to
whatever the hell this person was
talking about i i apologize for that
profusely um
if i was broadcasting a reds game right
now i would just fire myself on air like
that guy did
um all right where am i here
i am indian live here and i'm also
uppercast
brahman so yes it is a problem a major
problem in india and has been for
thousands of years
i second the historical
brief overview that you read on your
podcast from an email last time
are we indians trying to solve the
problem yes is it nearly enough
not even close our constitution does
does provide provisions for reservations
in government jobs and education for
lower caste aka
scheduled caste which will
will be called sc from here on sc from
here on
people such as jesus this is like star
wars trying to know all these names
dalits as well as for
scheduled tribes st from here on people
in s the st
category are those which are believed to
have
lived here even before the aryans came
in and settled in the indian peninsula
in fact dr b r m bechderkar
who is considered the father of our
constitution was a leader in fighting
against
oppression of lower caste and belonged
to a lower caste system
cast himself side note he studied at
columbia
a feat your fat brain can only dream of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] i told you indian
people
love to break balls they're hilarious
uh reservations are similar uh
to affirmative actions in usa
has it helped these lower caste people
access better lives
uh the answer is in the stats quoting a
newspaper from 2019
the national family health survey
2015-2016
showed that 45.9 of st
population were in the lowest wealth
bracket compared with 26.6 percent
of the sc sc population 18.3
of obc's 9.7 percent of jesus christ
buddy
of other casts so yes there is still
much more to do okay everything those
stats were bad for people
in the lower end um
oh [ __ ] was did they tom just throw a
pick six
oh jesus the new orleans saints are
making the biggest mistakes you can do
right now you're pissing off tom brady
let's see what just happened here my
apology to people in lower caste systems
in india
oh
[Music]
you know that cornerback's keeping that
ball that's one for the trophy case
picking off tom brady who's probably
been throwing [ __ ] footballs longer
than that kid's been alive
um in the nfl oh it's becoming a blowout
here
um all right where am i
in fact uh
sorry people so yes there's so much more
to do the more stats you look at it
would be safe to assume
that the more evidence you'll find to
support the fact that it is a serious
problem
with the fact that you know you could
have like
a bill gates a [ __ ] jimi hendrix a
michael jordan uh
[ __ ] edith wharton did i cover all my
tracks there mr miyagi
living in the [ __ ] lower caste system
and they can't make the karate kid they
can't get on the bulls they can't make
albums they can't live on their own
creepy [ __ ] island with their [ __ ]
reading glasses i mean
people should be able to see how far
their talents take them
um it's why there shouldn't be something
like that and it's also why if you are
successful
you have a huge responsibility to try
and help out others because people
helped you out you know unless you're a
trust fund kid
then you have a whole other problem you
know what i mean your whole career path
has been decided
the gene pool with which that you can
[ __ ] breed in has been decided it's a
really weird thing
um all right so anyway uh reservation is
uh reservation is a big issue in india
with uppercast folks out here staunchly
against it doesn't this sound familiar
uh current right-wing government that we
have does not help much
that sounds very familiar uh there is
also an argument that reservation
only helped the steady the already
well-off in the
s-e-s-c category
uh usually usual reason quoted in sc
category folks do not usually meet the
education requirement to qualify for
these jobs
this stance can be criticized as as it
is the very
oppression of these people historically
that has stopped them from accessing
good education yes
and thus opportunities under reservation
as well yeah and then it becomes this
self-fulfilling prophecy
that they're not good enough to do the
job when they haven't had access to the
tools that they need
um yeah that is still a big problem in
this country
um on the other side there is the
clamoring there is clamoring that
reservation
reservation should be economic
background based
instead of cast-based uh this could
bypass the problem of the already
well-off getting more
opportunities in sc and st i have mixed
feelings about this one
uh let's dig a little deeper you must
understand that
similar to racism in the united states
this problem is not just about economics
as it's also cultural what does that
mean you'll find the
sc and st category people working jobs
which we consider
as below dignity natarus
i don't know what that means nat taurus
of them all are
manual scavenging and sanitary worker
jobs
uh to get more info just do a google
search and see how many sanitary workers
die
in india every year just because of the
lack of proper
safety equipment which is not funded
properly
it's a problem with the upper class and
cast just
choose to ignore and it's just invisible
to us
you'll find majority scs working in this
profession
all right we're almost to the end here
it's very similar to the u.s sending
in black folks to do the hardest of the
risky jobs in fighting their wars
making them live in the highly polluted
areas
i don't think the situation of scs and
st's is going to change
for another century unless we start
having conversations here in india
about caste system and class issues both
you may
uh think what i've done as an
upper-class
uppercase brahm oh you might think what
have you done
to improve this their situation to that
i would say not enough
except for reading books to enlighten
myself about this issue and donate to
ngos who work on similar issues lastly
there are some books you and your
readers can go through to understand
more about this problem
uh number one the argumentative indian
uh number two annihilation of caste
uh number three india after gandhi uh
finally i hope you were still doing your
meditation uh no i got away from that
i've been listening to you for a long
time and i
as i as long as i can think of and it
has helped me get
through uh a lot of boring office work i
have seen you evolved
into a better person thank you except
for the occasional angry rants against
women
guilty as charged after marrying the
amazing me and becoming a father i hope
to see you perform
live someday keep on keeping on and go
[ __ ] yourself dude i would love to get
back to india to do another show
hopefully
in a uh
in a covid free world i can do that
because i
i [ __ ] loved going over there i loved
the people over there
and um it was just a great time
all right um jesus christ can you
imagine if old dumb me read india after
gandhi
jesus christ i should do that to try to
balance out all the booze i [ __ ]
drank in my life
all right california energy deficiency
jesus christ we're going deep this
[ __ ] we billy bronze balls
[Laughter]
as a california resident listening to
your podcast last week you mentioned
how relieved you were that the state is
mandating to switch for trucks to run on
electric
trucks i used to be in the this camp as
well until i realized how efficient
the electric grid is in this state
particularly when the sun
is blotted out by smoke from huge fire
oh stop it
now they're not saying they're going to
be solar-powered
the state relies on sun and wind for its
electricity all right but jesus christ i
i just
i don't understand
[ __ ] people they're just against
cleaner
stuff i just don't [ __ ] get it
they're just against helping out poor
people
they're just against [ __ ] everything
and clearly what the [ __ ] we're doing is
not
working it's not working it's not
[ __ ] working and any time
somebody tries to do something new they
just try to pick out a [ __ ] problem
with it
yes if there was fires 24 [ __ ] seven
yes there would be a problem relying on
the solar but
what about the other 300 [ __ ]
50 [ __ ] days of the year it's not
cloudy
all right anyway
um and the reason we had blackouts are
because we didn't have enough sun
and shortfall and a shortfall in wind to
keep up with the demands of the grid
um adding a bunch of trucks to the
already
underperforming grid is a recipe for
disaster no it isn't
i i don't i i think we just need to
invest more money into that grid and i
think there's been enough oil men
and lobbyists preventing that you know
when the standing president is going
like uh
you know all of a sudden the wind
doesn't blow and you can't watch your
favorite tv show like he's literally
talking against it
um the state isn't planning accordingly
to handle this
uptick in demand i think we should be
building additional nuclear power plants
to replace the one and only nuclear
power plant in
diablo canyon which is scheduled to
close in 2025 nuclear energy is carbon
free
and surely our politicians see this
shortfall coming
could employ the scientific community to
find a safe way to deposit the waste
here's the deal if you just let
scientists solve all of this and you
didn't have politics involved
they could all get on the same page well
even then you'd have egos and they'd
want credit
i don't know uh nuclear energy is carbon
free already read that uh we get it that
climate change is presenting new
challenges to our state
that are incredibly difficult uh to
overcome but i've had enough
of blame placing how about we get some
logical solutions
implemented to help us overcome the
challenges instead of placing blame
i now this is what i agree with around
every freaking
uh time something terrible yet
predictable happens
since we are the home of technology
and the most affected by climate change
we should be leading the way in
innovation
innovative solutions but instead we get
an empty suit
with both palms up blaming humans
everywhere in the world
for why our state continues to burn
every year just my thoughts
and go [ __ ] yourself yeah well i think
the problem is everything has been
politicized
so um
i don't know somehow global warming
becomes a liberal or a conservative
[ __ ] problem
and the problem is is you have all of
this money this old money
in these old ways of doing things and
the way corporations
behave they don't want to lose any money
and uh it's it's gonna kill all of us
if we don't or it's i should say grand
greatly affect the way we're gonna live
so
um i don't know love that guy at tesla
or hate him
we need more guys like that who just can
act independently
and try to do something um i don't know
what i have no idea
um you know more than i do but like
i don't know dude i don't know it's 120
[ __ ] degrees out here last weekend
okay everything's on [ __ ] fire um
we got to do something and i believe
that we will do something um
but we have to stop attacking each other
which i kind of did at the beginning
that i probably attacked you so i
apologize there we go see
i'm trying to be an adult here all right
you are doing it too
fox and cnn bill you talk about the
trump
bad-mouthing soldier story as it is as
if it's a fact
it was told to a reporter an anonymous
yeah you're right you're right you're
right
i am doing it too because i don't read
because i ended up following up on that
story and it was just a rumor
the reporter who helped push the iraq
war narrative
and john bolton the guy who was one of
the architects of the cia
enhanced interrogation program trump has
badmouthed everyone who cares
all right i don't i don't go with that
that's you knowing that he's an idiot
that's you that like that's what trump
people are doing right now going like
i mean joe biden's just as bad it's like
he isn't mike pence isn't just as bad
nobody is just as bad as this guy i
really in the bottom of my heart
believe that this guy doesn't have like
isn't like
have some sort of mental problem
he has a horrific inferiority complex
and an astounding lack of empathy that
i care about that because i care about
people i care about this [ __ ] country
all right so that's where i draw the
line because i usually don't
you know you know i usually [ __ ] on both
of them
you know if you look at my track record
that's what i've been doing i trashed
[ __ ] trump and hillary
i've made fun of obama he made fun of
michelle
thankful to bush i made fun of them all
all right um the fact that this story is
coming
from uh this way from those people is
what's [ __ ] up
you parroting this stuff is basically
what the established wants uh yeah
ask jimmy dore what he thinks about
these guys if you don't believe
a person you don't know love you and
love ephesus from you're 100 right i
should i've done that a couple of times
um and i'm guilty of that this year
because i'm not living a life i'm just
staying at home i have nothing to talk
about so i'll just google news something
i read the [ __ ] headline and i riff
and because
part of the charm of this [ __ ]
podcast is me being [ __ ] uninformed
and saying dumb [ __ ]
it's not cool to do that about politics
so i i promise to stop doing that
uh all right new york's past and future
bill read your new york city thought the
city has been through numerous changes
over the last hundred years the most
impactful
is highlighted in this very compelling
report i've linked
uh new york city was essentially
bankrupt in the 1970s yes it was the
banks called the city's bluff
when it came to what they would do uh
to what they would do to
restructure literally the entire new
york city economic
system public and private they took a
major hold of the city
and have been controlling every shift
it's had
this also deals with hyper nationalism
how it has been used to uh deconstruct
regimes
oh so banks have been running new york
city huh
i should read that um i'll get you guys
let me at least click have the decency
to click on the link here
okay there's it's a youtube video it's
called
oh my god it's two hours and 46 minutes
long settle in people
it's called hypernationalism by adam
curtis um
it's the full documentary check that out
wow
jesus christ thinking you're gonna need
a pot cookie after that one that way
that's that's gonna be some heavy
[ __ ] watching there
all right where the hell am i oh where
did it all go
oh look at that there's my trunk my 2020
patriots roster getting to know
everybody
um nikhil harry number 15.
joe thuney 62 i got the whole [ __ ]
offense defense down here
but what i don't have what i don't seem
to have
is my [ __ ] re oh i know why because
they weren't in that area okay
i'm back no i'm not back mmp contact i'm
back all right
bad trip all right oh the [ __ ]
buccaneers scored
24 14. here we go all right it's not a
blowout all right bad trip number one
dear billy shakedown street i don't even
know what that means i like it
sounds like a uh a failed pilot that
they were trying to pair with 21 jump
street back in the day of
when fox was a new channel dear billy
shakedown street
uh bad trips are like bad drunks you may
be in a bad mood
if you think about dumb [ __ ] that annoys
you but chances are
you'd giggle and laugh and talk a little
more like george carlin oh if uh this is
if if i took mushrooms that people for
some reason want me to do
uh you should do some research on micro
dosing
you will never hear a bad story about
that and it could
definitely help take the edge off in
terms of losing your [ __ ]
everyone will tell you it helps things
roll off
easier anger and sadness being the main
two
well my question about that is is it
just
numbing me from those or is it is it
actually truly helping me
where a painkiller doesn't truly help
make you better it just numbs the
information
it blocks the information going to your
brain right p.s here is my bad trip
story once in college i didn't go to the
bar
and ate mushrooms instead with a friend
i started thinking about how anti-social
i was
and felt bad for having to be different
a few million
moments later i realized i went to the
bar
five nights a week anyways and wasn't
missing anything uh
i'm a child of divorce and have some
ptsd
and nothing was triggered all right so
you just felt bad for a little bit and
then you realized it wasn't bad okay
all right i'll go with that all right
hey billy big nuts
um listen to your podcast
your monday podcast about the positive
mushroom trip
and wanted to weigh in uh i'm a super
laid back person
i've hardly ever worked up or stressed
and can normally just go
with the flow i was always nervous about
trying mushrooms because of the stories
i would hear from other people
everything from being stranded in space
trying to get a taxi back home to one
friend who tripped while camping alone
and thought bigfoot was coming to kill
him
turns out bigfoot was just a beaver
gnawing down trees behind
his tent at night parentheses they're
nocturnal
dude i don't need to be thinking a
beaver is a bigfoot
i'm not i'm not doing this [ __ ] people
you guys can try to convince me all you
want
i eventually got tired of hearing the
stories all of which were so different
and wanted to experience it myself i did
it two or three times and had nothing
but positive experiences
mostly just laughing my ass off with my
buddies
after these few times i tricked myself
into thinking nothing could go wrong but
i was mistaken
the next time i took them i did an
eighth
to myself which was way too much for me
roughly three grams
on the previous trips when taking an
appropriate amount
i felt like i was floating on a lazy
river just enjoying myself
but with the three gram trip the lazy
river turned into a [ __ ] white rapids
waterfall
i became extremely anxious and insecure
i wasn't able to focus on anything
without feeling nauseous and remember
desperately wanting to be home
i was at a concert uh i just wasn't
myself anymore
i was it was
i don't know he wrote it was i feeling
it was a feeling i'd never
want again but the beauty of mushrooms
is that
even the bad trips teach you something
after fighting those shitty feelings
for what felt like hours probably an
hour at the most i
slowly started to become myself again
and that was the beautiful part
i've never been so happy to be me the
bad trip had taken me so far away from
who
i was that it let me see myself from a
distance and show me how lucky i am to
be me
i'm truly a blessed person and i kind of
forgot that until i had my bad trip
so the moral of the story is to take the
appropriate amount for you
well how do i know that before i try
there's just too many variables here
if you just want to have fun and dip
your toes into the water do that
or you can dive in the deep end and
maybe not fully enjoy
it but still come away with some
powerful lessons
thanks for doing what you do it truly
makes people happy and can't wait till
we can all laugh at you in person again
take it easy all right well don't you
learn the same lessons with alcohol
you know i've definitely had the thought
of like wow i wish i was sober right now
i wish i wasn't puking
i wish i wasn't doing this in public i
wish i didn't say that
except i never learned from those
lessons did i well i eventually did
because i finally quit all this [ __ ]
um anyways all right that's it my
apology for just uh i really feel bad
about just
reading [ __ ] uh about politics and world
stuff uh and riffing on it i just feel
like uh you know
i shouldn't be doing that the world has
changed enough now there's people just
walking up shooting cops now evidently
this is
stupid this i i i so i won't do that
anymore right my apology i was just
[ __ ] around
and uh i should do that all right so
that's it
um by the way horrifically horrifically
[ __ ] underrated i finally listened to
the first
chicago transit authority album i was in
my car last night driving to two
stand-up spots and i was listening to it
like this is one of they're one of the
most unbelievable [ __ ] bands of all
time one of the most underrated bands of
all time
their [ __ ] horn section and i i don't
know who wrote that arrangements on some
of those songs
like like face melting level [ __ ] and i
was stoned sober listening to it um
i highly recommend um
the first chicago chicago transit
authority album
um it's it's unfucking believable
and now all of those stories of jimi
hendrix falling in love with the band
loving terry cath
and uh bringing them on tour to open for
for them i can't imagine what those
shows were like i i got i got to look
to see if there's any footage of it i
mean it's incredible
um so anyways that's the podcast uh go
patriots go buccaneers um
i'm kind of rooting for everybody the
[ __ ] buffalo bills look good
they were playing the jets everybody
seems to look good against them sorry
new york but that's just the truth
um but who knows who knows uh this is
probably the biggest obviously the
biggest chance of somebody else to win
the east the afc
east in a long time and i know the bills
fans they've been waiting a long time so
we'll see what will happen
that's it thank god for football uh go
[ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in on you
on thursday
you